diana has questions Ben's yet what did
you guys talk about at the dinner table
when Ben was 10 couldn't be politics
in-law policies or could it and she's
looking for some parenting advice we
talked about everything one of the rules
I had was that I never thought that I
had all the answers so I was you
remember I would ask friends of mine
were very intelligent people over would
they be over for dinner and I'd
encourage you to ask questions of them
because they were more expert in certain
areas I was although we talked about
everything we talked about politics we
talked about music classical music we
talked about sports a lot the this is
part of an essential lesson I think and
that is that it is imperative that
parents take their child's questions
seriously I always took your question
Siri and your sisters and your questions
seriously and I think that's vital I
think it's vital so the child feels
respected no matter what the question it
may seem silly to you but it's not silly
to them and I think that's really
important